auf und davon mit der Mobiliar
Versicherungen und Vorsorge
[Applaus]
in Schweden wollen die Gäste der
rotzlars so richtig ins Schwitzen kommen
Auswanderer Jonas feiert daher zum
ersten Mal die Sauna ein
bisschen
Sauerstoff und das Problem ist wenn die
Türen aufmachen
mit großen Träumen brechen Anita Thomi
und aller egerta nach Griechenland auf
ihr Plan Ferien für Reptilienfreunde
anbieten
doch kaum angekommen der große Schock
ihr Heim brennt bis auf die Grundmauern
ab sie verlieren ihr ganzes Hab und Gut
[Musik]
aus dem Menschen am Meer in Kanada
wollen Barbara hasenmüller und ihr
Partner Thomas Range ein luxuriöses
Gästehaus mit sieben Zimmern machen
alles was sie besitzen stecken sie in
das Projekt während Barbara den
baumanagt Job Thomas in einem Café
in Schweden übernimmt Familie Rotzler
eine Ferienanlage mit 20 Gebäuden und
mit ihr viel Arbeit Mobiliar und noch
mehr Kram
[Musik]
angekommen müssen sie schon alles für
den Gästebetrieb vorbereiten
bei der Besichtigung der Zimmer machen
sie einen überraschenden Fund
tatsächlich
[Musik]
noch war der Kammerjäger nicht da aber
rotzlars haben momentan sowieso andere
Probleme in weniger als 8 Stunden kommen
die ersten Gäste
jonas hat Decke Wände und Fenster in der
Gaststube frisch gestrichen mehrere Tage
arbeitete er daran oft bis spät in die
Nacht
auch Nachbar Öl packt mit an er kümmert
sich um die neuen Lampen
gut gute Nacht
ihr kennt sie da etwas
alle helfen mit Sabrina bereitet mit den
drei Kindern die Gästezimmer vor
trotz Zeitdruck rotzlar sind die Ruhe
selbst
die Ferienanlage der Auswanderer liegt
an einer Nationalstraße sie verbindet
die Orte bolognes im Norden und Falun im
Süden
Verpflegungsmöglichkeiten gibt es außer
bald bei rotzlars kaum
[Musik]
zwei Reisende wollen hier Pause machen
das machen wir aber wenn man noch nicht
offiziell ja
die sechsjährige Fiona übt schon mal
servieren
so der andere construction
[Applaus]
oh
Reiz in die ganze
harmlos bis zu 60 Personen können
rotzlars beherbergen
[Musik]
die ersten Gäste bringen sie im großen
Gästehaus unter
eigentlich hatten sie für die Gruppe das
kleinere Gästehaus vorgesehen doch das
muss noch vom Kammerjäger inspiziert
werden
und dann ja dann wissen wir was Problem
ist das Problem beheben
[Musik]
die Tavernen an der Hafenpromenade in
Koroni sind alle geschlossen
es ist Winter auf dem griechischen
Peloponnes
Lucky ein Nachbar hilft aller und Anita
gut sechs Monate sind seit dem
verheerenden Feuer vergangen
Anita trennt den Brandschutz mit den
Steinen terrassieren sie das Gelände
Metallplastik und Glas werden entsorgt
identifizieren
[Musik]
was im Sommer gänzlich fehlt gibt es im
Winter fast zu oft kalten Wind und
heftigen Regen
[Musik]
die Emmentaler reißen nicht alles ab auf
dem bestehenden Fundament wollen sie das
Haus wieder aufbauen
noch immer fällt es aller schwer den
Verlust des Altenheims zu akzeptieren
ist wollen sie weiter benutzen aus dem
kaminstein will aller einen Schacht für
Kabel und Wasserleitungen bauen
[Applaus]
Schubkarre und Schubkarre es ist ein
mühsamer Weg bis alle und Anita hier
wieder wohnen können
[Musik]
[Applaus]
langsamer als gedacht geht es auch bei
Barbara hasenbühler und ihrem Partner
Thomas range in Kanada
hatte einen Unfall vor drei Wochen hat
sie sich auf der Baustelle den Knöchel
gebrochen
fahren
aber jetzt langsam geht's
Barbaras Unfall kommt zu einem denkbar
schlechten Zeitpunkt denn der Umbau
ihrer Villa zu einem Gästehaus muss so
schnell wie möglich fertig werden
[Musik]
auf Prinz Edward Island beginnt die
lobste Season und mit dem Hummer kommen
bald auch die Touristen
[Musik]
Thomas muss nun anstelle von Barbara den
Laden schmeißen mit den Hunden rausgehen
ist dabei noch das geringste
Hasen jetzt kannst du mich Assistent
hier das bitte mitnehmen
[Musik]
die Bremse dann da unten noch loslassen
in dem Bereich
bis vor einem Tag durfte Barbara nur
liegen den Umbau beaufsichtigen
unmöglich
alles gut brauchst du sonst noch was nee
sonst habe ich alles
Laptop ist da
und das spannende für mich ist dass ich
all die Sachen die ich wirklich nicht
gerne mache
jetzt wirklich ja hier faktisch umsetzen
muss
fängt in der Reihenfolge Worst Case
Szenario angefangen alles was mit
construction zu tun hat
zweitens alles was mit Küche zu tun hat
drittens einkaufen war alles an mir in
den letzten Tagen Wochen
bin ich happy in der Situation nein bin
ich nicht aber hilft ja nichts
wir machen weiter haben wir beide
entschieden und machen das Beste aus der
Situation
wo ist
Bravo ist cool
ob es Thomas gefällt oder nicht er ist
nun Bauleiter Koch und Krankenpfleger
[Musik]
fast fertig dank der tatkräftigen
Unterstützung von Öl und seiner Frau Eva
[Musik]
bei Familie Rotzler in Schweden können
jede Sekunde die Gäste eintreffen
nur noch wenig erinnert an das Chaos das
noch vor ein paar Stunden in der
Gaststube herrschte
jetzt muss nur noch der selbstgebackene
Kuchen in die Kühlvitrine dann ist
eigentlich alles parat
herzliche Kurzschluss
[Musik]
ja
die Kühlvitrine ist ausgestiegen
ausgerechnet jetzt
[Musik]
muss er sich später kümmern hallo
mein Name ist Jonas
wir haben Shetland sheeptokies in the
house die vier kommen aus Stockholm und
wollen auf der Ferienanlage skolche
Gordon das Wochenende verbringen
[Musik]
so if there is something Messing if you
need something just Hellas
we will not come to make the Bads if you
want us to make it we come okay perfekt
perfekt
die vier Jungs haben Halbpension gebucht
falls das Zimmer
da ist mega schön
Jonas muss das Abendessen auf den Tisch
zaubern ein Drei-Gänge-Menü
[Musik]
der ehemalige Qualitätsmanager hat eine
Stunde Zeit zum Kochen
zum Hauptgang gibt es Lachs mit Gemüse
und Reis zur Vorspeise einen Salat am
besten ist
für dich selber kochst es funktioniert
in der Regel eigentlich immer am besten
die Jungs genießen schon den selbst
mitgebrachten
[Musik]
und Eva sind zum Abendessen eingeladen
ein Dankeschön für ihre Hilfe so jetzt
[Musik]
gerade so geschafft
rotzlars ruhiger Art zahlt sich aus
einmal mehr
[Musik]
in Griechenland sind selbst einfache
Dinge für Anita und aller nicht mehr
selbstverständlich
fließendes Wasser gibt es nur hinten im
Garten
in der Garage unter dem ehemaligen Haus
haben sie einen Teil der Schildkröten
und die 24 Giftschlangen untergebracht
monatelang warteten sie auf die
Einfuhrbewilligung für die Tiere
schließlich 9 Wochen nach der
Auswanderung konnte aller sie mit einem
Lieferwagen im Emmental abholen
und irgendwie
jeden Zentimeter der Garage nutzen Sie
für Ihre Tiere
die Riesen Schildkröten verbringen die
kalten Nächte unter der Wärmelampe
aber
[Musik]
und Anita müssen improvisieren
sobald die griechische Wintersonne stark
genug ist bringen Sie Olga MIMO und
binden ins Freigehege
[Musik]
trennen
ja
im Moment
[Musik]
die Tiere sollen so schnell wie möglich
wieder ein richtiges Zuhause bekommen
[Musik]
vertauschte Rollen im Menschen am Meer
in Kanada
Klasse
dreimal am Tag muss nun Thomas die
Handwerker bewirten vor dem Unfall
machte das Barbara
Barbara muss sich immer noch schonen ihr
unerschöpflicher Elan wurde ausgebremst
was bleibt Telefonieren auf dem Sofa und
das noch mehrere Wochen lang
für mich ist es extrem schwierig und es
ist für mich ein richtiger Volk es ist
wirklich Erfolg
seit dem Kauf der Liegenschaft 2019 war
es vor allem Barbara die das Projekt mit
dem Gästehaus vorantrieb Thomas gab ihr
Rückhalt aber blieb im Hintergrund
als gastroprofi weiß er genau wie man
Gäste glücklich macht mehr als 25 Jahre
lang arbeitet er in diesem Metier aber
einen Umbau zu koordinieren ist für ihn
totales Neuland
durchschnittlich acht Handwerker
arbeiten gleichzeitig auf der Baustelle
das Kernteam als solches macht wirklich
ein super Job wir haben ein paar
hick-ups hier und da wo mir auch ein
paar Sachen wieder von vorne machen
dürfen hier in dem Raum wo wir uns jetzt
beispielsweise befinden Zimmer 5 so
haben die die Elektriker die hier diese
hitpumps eingebaut haben haben sie
einfach da in die bereits fertige
Konstruktion einfach wild
reingeschnitten und Sachen rausgebrochen
und jetzt muss mir den ganzen Bereich
hier einfach komplett noch mal wieder
reparieren und das ist nicht nur hier so
sondern das haben sie ihm fünf Zimmer
gemacht das heißt sicher anderthalb
Wochen verloren
[Applaus]
es ist wie so oft auf Baustellen alles
dauert länger
so
what's going
quick video nicht ohne Grund hat Barbara
vier Wochen als Puffer für die
Bauarbeiten eingeplant
jetzt ist noch relativ viel Material
auch erst geliefert worden also Sachen
die wir im letzten Jahr ja schon
bestellt haben und einfach ja auch die
Lieferfristen immer wieder mal
verlängert worden sind aufgrund von
diversen Umständen und so haben sie
natürlich jetzt viel auffüllen können
das ist natürlich schön zu sehen das mit
der wieder in grünen Bereich kommen
die Jungs sind ziemlich stolz und das
sieht gut aus
bisschen viel
ein das geht keine Minute klack
IG
noch davor und so und dann ist das
bündig
cool
ja
nur noch sechs Wochen dann wollen Thomas
und Barbara an diesem Tisch zahlende
Gäste bewirten willkommen
[Musik]
in Schweden heißt Jonas seit Stunden die
Maske die traditionelle Holzsauna ein
ihre Stockholmer Gäste wollen ins
Schwitzen kommen
das Anfeuern ist eine Wissenschaft für
sich Jonas hat sich bei Vorbesitzer ok
informiert wie er vorgehen muss
auch ein heißes Bad im Hotpot wollen die
Gäste nehmen
nur der ist noch lange nicht
betriebsbereit
du Deckel vom Ufer ist wohl lengericht
sie Stoffwechsel
und dann hättest
mit Wasser gefüllt
[Musik]
ein weiteres Problem auch der kesselrind
das Wasser ist fast draußen jetzt kann
er einen Versuch wagen
viel Zeit hat Jonas nicht mehr die vier
Jungs können jederzeit von ihrem Ausflug
zurückkommen
[Musik]
jonas will es perfekt haben denn
zufriedene Gäste geben gute Bewertungen
ab das ist für den Aufbau des Geschäfts
wichtig
[Musik]
noch wichtiger aber Jonas scheint sich
in seiner neuen Rolle als Gastgeber wohl
zu fühlen
wenn am Schluss merkst das Cash happy
sind und das ist cool finde und sie sich
bedanken dann hast du
erwartet
keine danke schön und wenn der Gäste und
die wirklich zufrieden machen
das ist doch geil oder das macht doch
glücklich oder
während sich die Gäste entspannen geht
es für Jonas und Sabrina noch lange
weiter
Öl verknallt er hilft dir heute der
Kuchen
damit ich mit dem Kind früheren
[Musik]
der Garten ist nur einer der Vorteile
von Anitas und alas neuer bleibe in
Griechenland die Dreizimmerwohnung ist
auch groß genug damit der Rest der
Schildkröten hier überwintern kann
schon kurz nach der Feuerkatastrophe
durften die beiden hier einziehen
die Wohnung gehört Hans seine Tochter
hatte den Schweizern das Haus das
abgebrannt ist verkauft
Ferien
[Musik]
Tag für Tag pendeln sie nun mit
Ruine ihres Hauses
[Musik]
[Applaus]
neben der Ruine lassen Sie ein
Sanitärhaus bauen ein Haus mit Bad und
Küche ihr Ziel so schnell wie möglich
wieder hier oben wohnen
[Musik]
das Wetter ist gut genug die
Riesenschildkröten dürfen wieder einmal
Sonnenbaden
Anita und aller ziehen im neuen
Sanitärhaus Kabel ein
der gelernte Elektriker und die
ehemalige Disponentin haben schon ihr
Haus im Emmental gemeinsam renoviert
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Anita und Allah sind rund 20 Jahre ein
Paar in dieser langen Zeit haben sie
schon so manche Hindernisse gemeinsam
überwunden
der griechische Alltag hält immer wieder
neue Überraschungen für Sie bereit für
Menschen
nicht nur die andere Mentalität ist eine
Herausforderung auch die Finanzierung
ihr Geld wollten sie in Ferienhäuschen
investieren jetzt müssen sie damit
zusätzlich den Wiederaufbau ihres Hauses
bezahlen wenn aus rund läuft
mit finanzierten
oh wenn das nicht passiert
wirklich schwierig werden
den Antrag für die Wiederaufbauhilfe
haben sie beim griechischen Staat
gestellt
ob sie aber tatsächlich Geld bekommen
ist offen
[Musik]
alles im Griff haben dass es in Kanada
nun Thomas Aufgabe bei Joe ein Ding der
Unmöglichkeit
erst sind ganz spezieller Typ Mensch und
wir sind immer dran nicht so richtig
kennenzulernen und wie üben noch so ein
bisschen Kommunikation um erreicht ihn
auch nie und dann taucht dann plötzlich
auf und dann
ist das immer so okay eine verwirrende
Situation durchaus
Gärtner joe ist ein Unikum er kommt und
geht wie es ihm passt heute will er den
rasentennisplatz vorbereiten
young
auf Joe sind die Auswanderer angewiesen
er ist der einzige der die
Bewässerungsanlage kennt
jetzt schnell hinterher weil wir müssen
checken ob das Wasser im richtigen Ort
rauskommt bevor irgendwas kaputt geht
der Hahn ist offen doch wo bleibt das
Wasser
oh fresher ist der das ist jetzt gut
Thomas scheint sich so langsam in seine
neue Rolle einzufinden allem Stress zum
Trotz
[Musik]
einmal die Woche gehen Anita und aller
zum Abendessen eine Etage höher
jeden Dienstag kocht Hans für sie ist
offen
hi guten Abend so jetzt können wir
wieder in der Küche Hans ist Holländer
und selbst vor 20 Jahren ausgewandert er
war es der Anita und ihre
Schwiegereltern durch das Feuer gelotst
hatte
das gemeinsame Erlebnis verbindet
Hans überlegte nicht lange und gewährte
den Schweizern in seiner
Einliegerwohnung Unterschlupf
sie hat ja nichts mehr und unterlicher
dazugeben
habe ich nicht gewusst aber war für mich
auch kein Problem und ich freue mich
noch immer dass es so ist so Hans ist zu
einem guten Freund geworden dessen Rat
sie schätzen bald schon wollen die
Emmentaler ihre erste Erlebniswoche für
Reptilienfreunde anbieten anita hat ein
Konzept gemacht und einen Flyer kreiert
diese drei Wochen
wo man auswählen kann wann man kommen
möchte
erzählt dass die Unterkunft noch nicht
bei uns ist weil wegen dem Brand aber in
einem Hotel in Corona
die Erlebniswoche ist ein erster Versuch
ihren auswanderungstraum wieder aufleben
zu lassen
[Musik]
besseres Leben als gutes Leben das
wünschen wir uns jetzt
[Musik]
7 Uhr in der Früh in Schweden
Abreisetag auf der Ferienanlage scall-
die Nacht war kurz wie schon so oft in
den letzten Tagen
bis später abends stand Jonas in der
Küche jetzt muss er die Schlussrechnung
für die Gäste vorbereiten
Müdigkeit hin oder hier das
Frühstücksbuffet muss fertig werden
[Musik]
der erste Gast hat schon Hunger
not got
[Gelächter]
ihren Gästen machen die rotzlers einen
Sonderpreis umgerechnet knapp 500
Franken müssen Sie für das Wochenende
bezahlen
was man haben alles was mich extra
deckt das wunderbar für uns und es ist
einfach Trainingslager
hey wie muss ich noch nicht morgen
festgestellt dass man da umstellen wir
haben festgestellt dass man wirklich und
systemine bringen jetzt
immer das alles umsetzen
[Musik]
Reisen zufrieden ab
haben die Feuertaufe bestanden
wurde neues hier
je näher die Hauptsaison auf Prince
Edward Island kommt desto häufiger
klingelt bei Barbara und Thomas das
Telefon
[Musik]
Telefon bitte
sorry
ein Gast möchte eine ganze Woche buchen
doch dafür müsste er während des
Aufenthalts das Zimmer
wechselnights that you are in the
executive seed sweet you will get it to
the price from the double room
so you know you have the same price for
all 7 nights
very happy family gemacht
und auf revenues zu deutsch Einnahmen
sind Barbara und Thomas dringend
angewiesen
[Musik]
seit über zwei Jahren geben Sie Geld aus
ohne das groß etwas reinkommt
immerhin der Umbau macht sichtbare
Fortschritte auch wenn noch viele
Details fehlen
und auch bei Barbara geht's bergauf drei
Wochen noch und sie wird einen Gehgips
bekommen
[Musik]
Doppelzimmer 5 und das ist erste Zimmer
wo mehr vermietet werden haben 26 Juni
ich freue mich drauf
Schlusspunkt
Schlusspunkt und
Anfangspunkt wartet
am besten
[Musik]
und so geht es in Kanada weiter wenige
Tage vor der Eröffnung stellen die
Handwerker fest dass die Gästezimmer
kein warmes Wasser haben
[Musik]
die fabrikneuen Durchlauferhitzer müssen
ersetzt werden bei den Auswanderern
liegen die Nerven blank warum
um alles in der Welt tun wir uns das
hier eigentlich wirklich an ist es das
wirklich wert
in Schweden hat Tochter Fiona ihren
ersten Schultag
[Musik]
das Verhältnis zu Nachbar Öl bekommt
erste Risse
selbstlos ist wie sich am Anfang
ihren Traum näher sie empfangen erste
Gäste
er ist sehr gefreut auf euch
sie wollen der Reisegruppe etwas
Besonderes bieten und führen sie zu
einem versteckten Wasserfall doch von
Reptilien keine Spur
keine Musik
[Musik]
auf und davon mit der Mobiliar
Versicherungen und Vorsorge